everybody hello hello i'm sorry for the late start let me add my music
this is my mind my head right now this is actually how i feel is to be in my head at the moment i'm sorry oh i'm so tired i'm okay um i was like actually uh
I was actually like this close, this close to the castling stream the day because I was like last yesterday was so much.
It was a lot.
Like I know, okay, guys, you're like, oh, but you, you and it's you only did like an hour stream yesterday.
But like, no.
Because like I can't say yet as to what I was doing yesterday.
it was all related to uh behind the scenes stuff so um it was all behind the scenes stuff and um and it was like related to also like related to a sponsor too and let's just say that it went super over time that after after um after we were finally done i'll get i can tell the story next week I'll just say that you guys will get the full story next week as to why I'm like so fucking tired
you'll find out next week and I'll tell the whole story um but you'll and then you'll understand you'll watch back to this spot and you're like I understand now I'm surprised you're even alive
um but like it was so much stuff going on that when i woke up and i had to wake up early today because my cleaner was coming in today um um you know like the monthly cleaning um i actually asked if they could like come here come in earlier because usually they do it like once every month um so obviously the month hasn't ended yet for uh you know for for you know that you're supposed to come in november instead of october because i also recently you know did a deep cleaning of um of my apartment i wanted the cleaner the my actual cleaner come in early so she could finish the job uh you know with the actual cleaning supplies and like mopping and everything and um and like the vacuums too like i wanted and then obviously the closet hasn't been like uh vacuumed in a very long time as well as like you know um and also i was like clean around in general so i wanted the the cleaner to like you know get that shit done with um um to finish the job and everything um so i had to wake up at nine
in the morning today as well um just because like um just because she was coming in early too so uh at 10 so that's why i'm like extra tired as well i was like no No canceling Doki you show you need to give them 24 hours that you know like 24 hours if you're going to do a Kenny Cancellation or you pay the fee So I was just like So I was like,
okay, okay, I can do this I also had so oh my gosh, this song
It's like a song I This is my Minecraft playlist right now This is my the usual Minecraft playlist When I play this game So basically I was so fucking busy today And yesterday because of all this stuff going on Anyway Anyway before we begin Before we begin It is hashtag add time So for those who don't know or who don't follow me on Twitter I had a big announcement yesterday um at 5 p.m pst don't worry let me grab the picture real quick um but yes it is another dream come true for me uh for those who don't know where the fuck did i save also like where the fuck did i save this uh so this is another dream come true but oh my gosh this picture is so big let me i officially have professional gaming gear yeah the dokey bird controller yes you can now get your very own uh dokey a bird ps4 control ps5 sorry playstation the ps4 sorry play playstation controller yeah and it's and there's and you can have like there's like regular controller bindings and then there's like fps uh controller
bindings and then um there is um um there is also like uh my custom uh bindings for the controller so there's no no this is there's this is like a uh they have like various options obviously the more customization you want your controller the more expensive it gets um but let me send out the post uh let me uh yeah i'm sleepy i didn't drink coffee at all too because i felt like i'm gonna take a nap right after the stream so i didn't want drinking coffee uh kelly thank you for the super chat thank you thank you pre-ordered the controller can't wait for you to come thank you i actually have out what listen to this oh oh you hear that those are what you call the smart controller because like you don't have to push all the way so they're like keyboard presses too so you can you can hear like the what are they called the bumpers the bumpers in the back um it's like an instant press so uh you don't have to press it all the way down and then there's like i have back so they're like fancy fancy
yeah you hear that wow that this can be yours if you pre-order with this link right now grab your own um playstation controller right now well not now it's like a pre-order but uh yeah look at that whoa and uh you can also add like little back pedals too so you can have extra buttons for your key buttons because you can use this on your PC whoa oh it's not clickable I'm so fucking sorry you can tell I'm tired you sort of tell I'm a little tired why is why are you not clickable I don't understand all right give me a sec i'm trying to figure out how to make you clickable all right do i have to do htpp https htps um okay would this make you clickable let me double check does this make you clickable oh it does okay there you go i did it guys i'm a professional swimmer um but yeah i'm so excited to work uh and collaborate with boy gaming um because they are the number one uh controller brand in japan and they've sold like 30 000 uh units so far uh not for me but like you know in general
overall for themselves like if i sold 30 30 000 units like after one day uh it'll be fucking crazy like I might as well get like brand deals with Nike or some shit like but like they've already sold like 3,000 units overall from all the collaborations and um usual sales they do and it's like um it's like they are the number one um uh controller uh controller custom controller brand in Japan as well so I was very shocked that they reached out to me um to do this collaboration um and I'm like and that they've worked with for this so you might see in the collaborations they've worked with a lot of other japanese vtubers and i'm their very first overseas vtubers that they've reached out to collaborate on it and they also worked with alliance like they worked with a lot of japanese esports teams as well as alliance uh too so you can see they've done with fanatic they've worked with fanatic they worked with um riddle um so like a bunch of like uh well-known jp esport orgs as And it is a
controller that is used by a lot of Japanese pro players, too.
So, you know, it basically elevates your gaming.
Or if you want to be a casual, that's okay too.
It is, it is, you know, Toki bird theme.
Yeah!
It's such a cool merch, honestly.
I think this is one of the coolest merch I've got.
This is a very unique type of merchandise, I guess, especially for my VTuber.
Because, like, you know, you don't really see that often.
You know, getting like a fucking professional controller, like Doki Bird branded controller and everything.
Like it's so cool.
Um, um, so like I said, there's like several presets that you can do for this.
So there's the design only.
So it's the normal controller without these.
I believe it's just like without these back pedals or anything.
But you do still get like, you know, the Doki Bird branding on it.
Um, so they're really cute.
You know, it's so clean.
like preters are up for one month um i believe um and others also so there's the fps config as well for this design so it comes with the two rear buttons and then the smart triggers which is this and no vibration too um there's an option to remove vibration on these controllers as well um but yes um if before you guys couldn't do shipping um it was a little bug slash glitch in the system so they accidentally like put in 400 kg versus 400 versus 400 grams um on on the like for shipping for the item for some countries so that's why like some of you guys weren't able to uh yeah 400 kg They accidentally put 400 kg versus 400 grams And that's why,
like, for those who weren't able to order from certain countries Because they made a little oopsie So if you weren't able to order it before because of that error Do not worry, you should be able to place your order now The heaviest controller in the world Not only is this my very first V2 PlayStation controller is also the heaviest they add like they added like tungsten steel into the controller so it's like meal more so me emmer me emmer or some like doors hammer yeah if you can lift this controller you are worthy and also I also had like the dokey bird custom config so there's like four rear buttons instead of just two so more key bindings that you can bind to your controller um but yeah it's it's it's really cool this has been like in the works for more than a year i think they've like contacted me like a year ago about this opportunity and we've been working with them for like you know we've been working with them there's lots of logistics and everything um but But also,
for those who are wondering, like, oh, what about an Xbox controller?
I'm only an Xbox controller user.
Well, if we make enough sales, you know?
Wink, wink, wink, wink, wink.
There might be a future opportunity with a new design, with a new design.
So it's like, you know, it'll be like a nice little thing for your dokey份 where you can hang up, like, you know, different controllers and stuff.
on the wall and it'll be a new design too so I'm saying you know if we if we have enough so then you know maybe you can complete the collection in some way you guys have to buy more for me man why don't you just buy the PlayStation 1 to hang on the wall
You gotta, you gotta, you gotta help out too, Matt.
Like, I mean, you guys, you're part of the dragons.
It can be a, yeah, it can be a decorative controller.
You know what to do, dragons.
Cyber, the US Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Obviously that is all like up in the air, like the Xbox stuff.
I know some of you guys were like, to have an xbox one as well but you know a little incentive chat just a little bit of an incentive for the future um um uh but yeah no i'm i i'm super duper excited in in general uh uh to to you know have this controller um as uh as something i could sell um you know as something to give you guys an opportunity to purchase as a dragon because you know it's so cool it's just really cool like a natural pro gamer like it doesn't have you don't have to customize it as like a you know a pro controller but you know like in general it's just such a cool opportunity i've never seen myself having like a a controller as a merch in general um um so it was very very exciting to work with void gaming uh work in void void gaming as well and for them to reach out to me too like i didn't reach out to them they they reached out to me with this opportunity i was like what the fucking course yes i'll say yes yeah like cool else you know like it it feels like such like
like it like um merch like for a for a merch opportunity it's such a rare opportunity to have because like not a lot of youtubers will get a chance to to like do this type of thing for merch so yeah i'm really happy so i hope you guys enjoy i hope you guys enjoy your controller uh when word does uh ship out and you know i would love to see you guys use use it use it to give but with the uh thank you the get you to sign the controller i mean if you take it to um any meet and greets where i'm signing stuff maybe maybe they have you know like those little signing things that they do there's a you know maybe there's like some meeting greets where there's like those like pen plot or shit maybe if you you know um do a perk plot or shit maybe uh or maybe if you uh if i'm at some land and then members there too and you and like i happen to be at that then that would be really hard to catch me though because like we found out that i don't really like lands much so that would be really hard to
catch me by so so maybe you'll catch maybe in like four to five years i'll show up to another land um man you think it was super chat thank you thank you praying for the giveaway to save me so i going on right now at the dokey merch twitter account for those who do use twitter um yes the dokey merch is officially affiliated with me i know i don't advertise it much but but um you guys want to have a chance to get it for free we do have a giveaway going on right now um um that you can i guess it's like yeah reply retweet and reply in the comments to um But you gotta follow the Doki merch account as well as the board gaming Twitter account as well.
Sorry my brain is super frazzled today.
I've been like really tired today.
I've been I've been like working a lot today.
So my mind is like extra frazzled.
But anyway, today hashtag ad over.
hashtag ad is over we're gonna be gonna play minecraft today I don't know does it seem like my brain is extra frazzle today I feel like I'm having trouble using words I feel like I am sort of having trouble right now um making sentences and making words make sense
English is very hard today.
Oh, but, but, but, so thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To avoid any completely unprecedented situation such as people crowding your plot, you should get stick enchanted with knockback launching ammo.
That's such a fucking good idea.
I'm going to rate that.
I'm going to screenshot this actually and give myself that power in the future.
So, today we closed the server down.
That was my solution to how to fix the problem.
And it was to close the server down.
So only I have access to the server right now.
For today.
So I can actually, you know, walk around.
And we won't have another incident in Dokila.
you guys want to hear the story of why i was so up i'm so up today um remind exclamation point remind me next week to tell you the story uh because it is a yeah it it's the story is a lot a lot of stuff happened yesterday i'm so i'm still i'm still so tired from it Guys,
I was this close to canceling today's stream.
Anyway, all right.
It's Minecraft time.
Minecraft.
Where's Minecraft?
Why did my Minecraft not show on the screen?
What the fuck?
It's stupid.
Hello?
Oh, there it is.
Minecraft time.
All right.
So I still have God mode.
Wait, is this the right?
It is, right?
Yeah, it is.
Okay.
What's the command to make it daytime?
Add.
Uh.
Maybe.
Did I fuck up?
Um, time.
Oh, there you go.
It's day now!
Yay!
I don't know how many seconds I've had.
I don't even know where I live anymore, right?
What the fuck?
Exiting lobby, PvP.
What happened here?
among us?
Yay!
Alright.
Wait, what's this?
What land is this?
What the fuck?
What did you guys build?
Vader land.
Oh, it's like a little enchanted forest.
There's so many trucking pot.
I'm so close.
I'm this close to breaking it.
I'm Oh, shit!
I swear to God, this doesn't happen often, guys.
Wait, that's so close.
Look at upside down.
Wait, does that say crime land?
Intrusive thought to be invaded.
What does that say?
Is that crime land?
Crimland?
Okay, it's crimland.
That's a crime.
actually sick i like that oh it's because his name is crim i thought it was like crime what the fuck happens in crime land is it like crime alley like yeah i was gonna say sorry i'm just having performance anxiety holy you think he counts his dogs he doesn't count his cows he doesn't know i bet crim doesn't even here anymore i mean not like he's dead or damn it crim i bet crim isn't even like online watching right now he won't know i can't be a griefer if i own the server he's gonna see not gonna see the stream guys is crim in chat right now i repeat is he in chat right now It's not griefing if I own the server.
I'm literally the CEO.
It's a CEO.
All right, what's this egg?
The egg church.
Oh, shit.
This is where all the eggs hang out.
Why is there a fucking dog in the egg church?
Laughy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's cool.
There's a church here, too.
I don't think I'll ever find Doki Lund again.
I read TP back to my house.
Actually, I don't even need to go to Doki Lawn.
I just remember there's nothing there.
It's the one that lays eggs.
Oh, tree house.
Oh, my God.
They built a little tree house up here.
Oh, that's cute.
He'll never know.
It's like my little bark.
That's cute.
El Spawn.
Oh, my God.
It's like a little rollercoaster too.
Oh.
That's really cute.
All right.
Did everyone build around me?
I bet you everyone build around Dookilat.
It's like at Disneyland, there's like all these little resorts and like malls and hotels and little like tourist traps outside of Disneyland.
Like that's you guys.
You guys are my...
You'll never compare to the real thing.
You're just a tourist trap.
That's a dookie lawn.
Okay, so.
Wait, okay, I was gonna say, how did you get in here?
What the fuck?
Who are you?
Who's in J22?
This is the admin?
I don't remember you.
What is this?
What is this area?
The dragon grave.
I don't remember no graveyard sanctioned next to my fucking house.
Who approved this?
Who approved this build?
This is the honor, so please don't deflate things.
Tom Atlas.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Dokeybird.
What?
The memorial dust was completed by.
And those were lost amid the stars.
I'm going to take this book right now.
I'm going to take it.
You'll never.
I delete the records.
I never forget.
We're forgetting right now.
We're going to...
She's erasing history.
I'm going to erase history right now.
I'm so cute.
Please.
Never forget, we're forgetting here.
Like...
That's right.
There was no book here.
That's it.
Where the fuck is...
I'm taking it.
Get this out of here.
It's...
I have an idea.
I'm building a wall, this unsightly godly sightly thing next to my house.
It's so creepy.
The internet stays out of my.
Alright, get this out of here.
The Google talkie, where the fuck is that?
We're building, we need to build a wall right now.
out.
Alright.
Pleasanton never existed.
Here you go.
Thank god I have admin power.
Admin release promo power.
Admin help me build a wall.
I know you're here at admin.
Admin.
Build wall with me now.
oh shit you're right what are you doing we should should be obsidian oh shit let's go change it to obsidian change to upset change the bedrock
here we go let's go let's go it says if it never existed we gotta keep the property value of chat yeah there we go he's not on your side he's on my side there you go i think that's good enough that's oh my god that's good that's right you can't even access a church that's so fucked up i didn't say that though i didn't
all right that's good good that's that's enough now no one can access the document
that's literally an unfree yes and and please give our dead don't talk dead don't Don't talk.
Why not build over it?
Because I don't finish the job.
That's too much effort.
Okay, there.
Oh, that's cute.
Look at that.
Now that's cute.
Seal it up.
No, I need you.
I need you guys to know what I did today.
Okay.
Anyway.
Doki is respecting the dead.
The dead don't talk.
Guys, no one is ruining my property value.
I don't want to look to my left and see a fucking grave.
So this is where my money goes to enabling a tyrant.
Thank you, the magenta soup poster.
Thank you, thank you.
Purified sleep.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
exactly look at that my property value is only going up now where's the where even is the book
that's right i have the only copy of your fucking religion that's right i'm erasing the i'm erasing history the textbooks are only written by winners and i'm the winner
I have the only copy.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, yeah, admin.
Make...
Oh, yeah, I can make it.
Oh, what's this?
The Phantom Thief Town.
Make it day, admin.
I demand for there to be light.
Oh, my God.
Is that Germany?
Is this Germany right here?
Oh, my God.
I'm in the...
I'm in Germany now.
He'll never know.
What if like...
No, what?
Oh shit, it's the little flying guns!
Wait, we have in the server now?
Oh my god, we updated the server!
What?
What a creeper.
Mine now!
Stop doing keys to click.
He has a happy gas!
It's my happy gas now.
Don't hurt the gas.
I'm keeping it.
Let me go.
Wait, how do I change the POV again?
Oh, not this.
What function key is it?
To change the POV of me on the happy gas.
F5.
Let me go.
Literally, I'm so happy.
And I water the way, water, water, and I water the way, water, water.
How do I get off?
Okay.
All right.
Admin, bring this happy gas back to Doki Line.
This is my, what's that word?
I have pillaged Germany and took...
I like how Mexico is next to Germany.
Bring this happy guest back to Dokilan.
It's mine now.
It's my hostage.
That's right.
He works for me.
You know what?
You don't want me even here.
It's almost the same.
Yeah, I have a hostage now.
I have a hostage, Germany!
Don't fuck with me.
Hello, Doki Bird.
I hope you enjoy this building.
Follow purple sides to get into that hall.
Oh, free flags.
Free one Austria.
Nice.
Like, guys, like, free flags.
You know, like, Germany and one Austria flag.
Uh...
Oh, you're right.
Admin, get over here.
And then change this one flag to bedrock.
Good idea.
Who gave me that idea?
I want this one flag to be made of bedrock.
Just this flag, though.
Go do it, Admin.
That's so fast I can't Hear that That's right, Tramony Your move now Who keeps giving your ideas?
They get to the dragon That gave me that wonderful idea I'm gonna show my twitch here I hope you enjoy Follow the And again, oh, okay, here, this is the side.
Your move, Germany, into the hall.
Is it here?
Oh, that's, oh, my God.
Is this, like, the delegation?
Is this here, like, a little...
This is, like, their little, like, little committee that they have here.
Like, that's freaking good.
Awesome.
That's amazing.
Don't piss it off.
Don't piss me off.
I have the power of bedrock on my side.
Yeah, is this parliament?
This is where you guys come in here to think you're safe from me.
That's looking right.
You think you can have...
You think you have a democracy here?
That's looking right.
Admin!
Replace all of these...
Replace all of these handles with bedrock.
of these animals with bedrock right now.
They don't have the power to vote here.
Doki, stop.
That's a key, right?
And someone stop.
Are you thinking you can vote in Doki land?
That's a key, right?
Get out of here.
Doki, you monster.
Doki, please.
she's silencing us you're the best part yes don't have you can't stop me the server is closed for you guys just gave them computers she would not turn in the has fallen all right oh this is phantom thief oh they rebuilt phantom thief they're in all the windows of bedrock of anakin they Thank you,
thank you.
Where's Mexico?
Oh, wait, I remember there's Mexico right behind me.
Wait, I'm heading to Mexico.
Give me a sec.
We're going to go to Mexico now.
Bum, bum, bum.
The tribe has turned a small home for a low-income family into bedrock.
Just remember, Germany.
I have one of your citizens hostage.
So don't mess with me.
Oh, Doe Kitty Land.
What makes this Doe Kitty?
I don't know what this build is for.
I don't know what this part is.
Mizuki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, what does that do?
What does the window escape button do?
Oh, there's Mexico.
Wait.
This is Mexico?
There's nothing here except...
There's nothing here in Mexico except for sheep and a horse.
Admin, I thought you...
I thought I told you to bring this...
To bring him home!
Exactly.
Admin, I thought I told you to bring this hostage back home to Doki Land.
Like, how is this Mexico?
I don't understand.
Or is this a Pia filter?
Yeah, that's right.
Bring him back to Doki Land.
That's right, Jeremy.
If you make a move, this guy gets it.
That's right.
Can't do anything with this.
Or your citizen gets it.
Alright.
He's my hostage.
Oh shit, there's like a little private ship here.
What is this?
High court of Doki.
There's like a little... What is this?
Prosecutor.
Defense.
Oh my god, it's like their little roleplay session.
Because we don't...
Because I am the law.
So you guys don't need it.
You don't actually need a system when I am the legal system.
Wait, what's this?
What is that?
What does this do?
Change Mexico to Fedora.
Oh, shit, it's croaky!
What happens when it's turkey?
You're not here.
How do we govern ourselves?
Yeah, that's
Oh my god, it's so cute!
Wait, I love this!
I love this build.
That's so fucking cute.
A giant-ass croaky, a croaky bear.
Yeah, if I'm not here to govern, that's not my problem.
Wait, there was like a floating ship up here.
Wait, what is that?
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
Is that Star Fox?
What is this?
Is this like a little...
Is this a falcon?
Like, is that plane?
Crokey is a bedrock.
Thank you, thank you.
I know it's definitely not the Death Star.
Signalis?
Wait, what is that?
What is Signalis?
Is that like a...
Is that a game?
Oh, I need...
Admin!
Make it day!
I'm too lazy to type it.
A game worth playing?
Oh, okay.
I'll look it up later.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is going on down here?
Holy shit.
It's like a fucking pit of animals.
He won't miss one sheep.
Oops.
Oh my god.
They're like invincible.
What is he going to do?
Count the sheep that he loves.
When you're fishing.
Alright, I'm in.
if there's a if there's a build you want tp me to just just take me there surprise me dumpy what is this turn them turn all the sheep in the bedrock it's like my little gift to this world i'm like santa claus you know you've been naughty uh don't be naughty okay i'll turn you in the bedrock i'm like santa and in one oh what is this what place is this oh it's like a little medieval town where am I admin
the void land oh the void land turn one of these buildings into no Joe I'm joking I'm imagine I was like turn one of these buildings into bedrock
Don't do it.
That's a joke, admin.
That's a joke.
In my house.
Whose house is it going to be?
If you're nice, if you're naughty, I'll turn you into bedrock.
If you're nice, I'll also turn you into bedrock.
It's all about the quality here.
the beginning and the old during the first day when not everyone was able to make it due to so many people joining extra stuck in the void and won't go mad thus becoming void goon i've kept the madness alive and where we are now more sane better organized you know what will make them even madder void lands in the future void i look look inside myself and see my heart as painted black are these all the void good members or cool is unstoppable.
Bedrock for all.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Alright, I'm picking a building.
Which building will I turn into bedrock?
Which will it be?
No, I took you.
My house took you down.
Which building do I pick?
He need me need money
Tokey they're home there's limits tokey tokey down Who would lose the gotcha who would lose the bedrock gotcha
Please I just paid the mortgage i just wasn't i was finally able to afford a home in the woodlands took you not my property should have thought it that before you build a cemetery next to my home
that's right all right let's see what would happen if i turn this entire building into better eye.
This is just like Gotha.
Let's see.
What happened?
Okay, first I need to figure out how to fucking get out of here.
That's it.
If I am unable to... Okay, okay, I left that.
I was able to climb down.
Come on, man.
The hardest house in the server.
All right.
All right, I picked my house.
That's right.
I picked it.
Yeah!
The dokey giveth and the dokey continue to give.
I did it.
One house is not like the other.
Which house could it be?
God is a divine punishment.
It ceases endless of bedrock.
What are the point goods to do?
My fucking house, bro.
I would say this is an improvement, honestly.
In fact, I would say this increases the property value because God has touches your home.
So, you know, that's God's gift to the Void Goons.
Yeah, it'll last for the ages, chat.
It'll last for a long time.
You know, if there is a nuclear bomb in the Voidlands, at least you'll live.
Yeah, see, you guys have a bunker now.
Look at that.
I giveth you guys a bunker in case there are...
atomic bomb drop down.
Whoa, my God.
I thought that bomb dropped down right now there.
Oh my God, is this my navy?
Wait, I have a navy right now.
Oh, that's cool.
The one dentist who doesn't recommend the toothpaste.
Mr. Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gus, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
The three little piggies building material really improved too.
But they started that with no way exit the hole that sounds like a you problem thank you the super chat thank you thank you oh my god that's so cool they felt like a fucking fake train station too for the dogs that's so i like that that's a little that's really cute yeah the little details too like look at that they even have cranes and everything oh that is so cool that's it that's right i claimed this for doke lawn give me a sec all right where's my sign why do i have like 20 of germany okay uh sign all right don't worry i'll claim this uh i'll claim this for dokey lawn property of dokey lawn oh there you go this is my navy now
owned by dokeybird there we go my boat now oh look at that my navy put at the highest point too property of dokey land look at that i made this If it is on my server, it's owned by me.
Oh, shit.
It's just like a little...
Like an air...
Oh, my God.
It is an airfield.
Like a little aircraft carrier.
Oh, that's so cool.
The little fucking plane, too.
Wait, that's so cool.
Oh, my God.
I love that.
I love that there's like...
They have like the little details that they did here.
I commandeered it.
Yeah.
Exactly.
all right we gotta get a hostage just in case like just in case the civilians resist my rule why is france here what the fuck is france doing here
we let france into my server
all right are there any hostages does he own any sentimental oh he owns the turtles all right admin we have kidnapped we have to kidnap one of their animals as like um what's that word as like a bargaining chip all right take one of those turtles and bring them back to dokey lawn
yeah as leverage yeah that's collateral take one of them home
Don't fuck with me.
Just remember, we own this.
Not the Taita.
Taita Turtle back to Doki Line right now.
Where the fuck are you taking?
What are you doing?
Where are you pushing him?
How far are we from Doki Line?
It's gonna take a while.
Color Blood.
Welcome to Doki Line.
tomato fire welcome welcome all right remember take it back to dokey land adamant remember i have one of your kids so don't fuck with me if you try to if you try to unclaim my ships i'll unclaim your turtle i'll unclaim your child that's fucking right remember that
This here, uh, cruelty.
The fuck is wrong with you?
Wait, I'm just making, um, I'm just, I'm just making sure, I'm just making sure that, uh, we have, you know, we have an understanding, chat.
I'm just making sure that we all have an understanding here.
Alright, admin, TP to another cool spot.
Go inside?
What's inside the ships?
It's just a ship.
Whoa, shit!
Oh, hello.
Shopping this drink.
For Jokey Bear from shopping.
Oh, buy my merch.
Yeah, buy my merch.
Sponsored by Gold for All Your Gold Needs Play for... Oh!
Oh!
That's so cute!
That's so cool.
Wait, you can make that many notes?
I didn't know that.
Oh, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, what is this I'm holding?
Bonk responsibly Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk
I like how it says bonk responsibly.
We know that's not gonna happen.
It's just gone.
What if you had bonk responsibly?
What do you guys want from me?
Welcome to the shop.
Our map artboard is forward and to the right.
Also, there's a skyscraper.
And the park is around the map art.
Can I have $10,000?
I was thinking, I could take the book.
Um.
Yeah, boy.
Thank you, Mr. Super Chat.
Thank you.
I know the owner of the shipyard.
I think she'll be honored to be robbed by you.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Oh, there's a waffle.
house oh my god wait what's over here we don't accept linden coin here dirty scammers no scams okay maybe uh maybe if they'll fight inside your animals i better see bloodshed in this waffle house oh shit he's not selling me anything i'm gonna turn him out there you not sell me anything you know what i'm gonna do to you
bedrock if you don't sell me anything that's right wait turn into day edmund stay time yeah where's the waffles in my waffle house what's this heart of the sea 192 diamonds
oh yeah How about I'll give you a fucking tomato?
Oh, I'll give you a flag of Germany.
Here you go.
Oh, wait.
I have a better idea.
Wait.
I think that's more valuable than diamond, honestly.
A valid exchange.
Have you been a naughty boy today?
see a dangerous choice of bedrock and even higher value oh my god there's a pokemon center
this october tona industry will return oh no no oh that's so cute it even does a little
Oh, that's cute.
It even has a little Pokemon Center soundtrack.
That's adorable.
I love that.
That's such a nice touch.
What's this?
Exit only?
Admin!
Fix it!
I like it, so...
Welcome.
Powdered in top chest.
wait list don't have what you're looking for place an order in this book oh okay that's cute they have like little order system too where am i did you fix it it was the exit where the fuck is the entrance then oh it's right here oh shit it was it was just right next to me like a spoiled chat I must know the entrance was right next to me.
I did not see no yellow paint.
There was no yellow paint.
Oh, admin.
Take one of their cats back to Dokilan.
We gotta have collateral here.
In case they try to fight back.
Take one of their cats back to Dokilan.
No, not the cats.
That's right, don't fuck with me.
I have your cats.
what is wrong with you all right nice oh look there's a little wait what's this infinite wisdom true true i hope you have a good day okay wait where's my sign
i have your cats don't mess with yokey bait If you, if you want to see them, if you want to see them.
There we go.
Now they'll know.
Blackmail.
It's not Blackmail, but I'm the only one who's a server.
It's just a suggestion.
It's just a very helpful suggestion.
Oh.
Look, it's dead!
Aww, they made like, it's like a little, like, Egyptian.
Oh, shit!
What's this?
It's a little sphinx.
How to play?
Blackjack tried to run away, watch the horse.
Blackjack says, keep gambling.
Wait, admin!
Take Blackjack home!
Take Blackjack back home!
I have Blackjack.
Jack
If you want him back
Build a giant dokey Here we go.
All right What that means for all right, how does it?
Put the diamond into the shulker.
Push the button.
You absolute monster.
Let me thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
I got very inspired by Stewie TK.
On my timeline, it was all about Stewie TK.
And he was like, he inspired me today.
Push the button.
Lose the gamble so I can make.
make a profit.
If the lever up, it is a single pull.
If it is down, it will keep rolling.
If it stops working up, but okay.
The horse piece is real.
Wait, which lever?
This lever?
Oh, it's this lever.
Blackjack, big book.
Come.
Oh.
What's the big book?
Oh, that's just a horse.
Give me a second.
I'm trying to read.
Book of fortune.
Let me take the book to type your fortune or even your frustration.
Don't break even.
Didn't break even.
Can't pay my taxes now.
All right.
I'm so glad you haven't found where I live.
I just started a few weeks ago.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes.
Wait, can I just pull this?
Okay, so I do need a deposit.
Okay, what?
There.
Where's the button?
Oh, it's here.
Push the button.
Oh, it's this box.
Okay.
I'm stupid.
Did I do it?
Where the fuck is my gambler?
I put a diamond in here.
How many diamonds do you need?
Oh, oh it's named tax money.
Oh, okay, I need a regular diamond.
Can you make a regular, okay, wait, I need a regular diamond.
I got this.
Okay, yeah, but I have an issue here.
Okay, wait.
What's this?
What is this in my inventory?
What is that?
I don't know what that was.
oh yeah let's gamble oh i oh it uses everyone let's go
oh i don't know if i won
it's like slides that's so cool i love that let's go gambling so what should make oh my god so we'll make a casino Oh, did I win anything?
Did it go up?
I can't tell.
Oh my god, you even make some sound when you win.
That's so cute.
You guys are so creative.
Wait, where does the money go?
Wait, where did the money go?
It's still 25.
Yeah, I won I won like twice in a row Where the fuck is my money?
This is why I took blackjack
It pops out Who the fuck?
Oh, oh, I see it Oh, that's cute Alright, I'm cashing out Oh my god, I'm up too!
Let's go.
I don't need Germany.
Mr. Broken Bun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's time for the revolution.
That taxes and oppression in Doki land.
Too much for the long goons to injure.
Rise up, long goons to fight against the tide.
This message is brought to you by the eight goons.
Admin, take me to where the eight goons live.
to the igloo's most sacred structure
oh check the map art oh where's the map art
oh no no no no no no no no no no no while he's trying to he's trying to figure out where is your sacred land I'm gonna find the map wall
That's rare I don't take kindly the threats And take a shot Every time Doki fills Oh there's a map wall Doki
Okay that one's good That one's my favorite Oh look there's dead There he is.
Look at him.
I'm always listening.
But I need to go back to Doki Lawn real quick.
Spawn Doki Lawn.
Where's my...
Where are my...
Captured horse from shopping district.
Captured gas from Mexico slash Germany.
Wait, where's the gas?
Wait, what happened to the gas?
Did he fuck?
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Look, he's so happy.
All right, admin.
We're going to make a prison.
Here we go.
All right.
No, he's right here.
We got to make a prison for the gas.
Admin, make a prison for the gas.
A bedrock prison.
A bedrock prison with a singular...
with a window so we all know he's in there.
I'll watch.
Shit.
Yeah, it didn't work.
Make sure he's not dead, too.
Make sure he doesn't die.
Make sure he doesn't die from it.
It's not happy anymore.
Okay, we all make sure he's like
hello fellow daft punk fan love your concert wish i saw it in light but i got to see justice live so big w thank you for the super chat saturn thank you thank you oh nice
this will be where he lives okay put all the prisoners in this chamber you literally ruin his smile be happy he'll be happier inside put all the other prisoners inside that's so bad put yes that's right put blackjack there too you took blackjack from me and the system was not a scam You turned my house into a bedroom,
you walked off my church.
I could not be happier.
Thanks, smile.
Thank you for the super channel.
Happy.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
It's beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
There we go.
Make the windows unbreakable, transparent barriers.
That's a good idea.
You heard that, Aiman?
Do that.
Except thinking about the super chat thing.
I don't know how you can do it, but make it happen.
You...
You can't see it.
You can't even go in.
That's right.
The bedrock TV.
It would be an honor.
My horse won't be the day.
Stop giving the demon.
Good ideas.
Now put the signs on this air.
So they know.
The illusion of freedom.
Put the...
signs here so they know.
Don't fuck with Doki Lund.
Well, not there.
Not there.
No, no, no.
Put it on the side.
We gotta be able to see it clearly.
Put it on the side, Admin.
Not there.
Wait, also, put this book in there too.
I also put this book in there too.
Make a podium.
Put this book in the fucking chamber as well.
Here you go.
I'll throw the book to you.
Put this book in there as well.
Hey, Doki.
You think I can hold this statue off the balcony?
I think I'll stay a while.
I don't stay a while.
Spin the bottom.
Magic, thank you for the super chat that you can take.
All right.
Can't even access the history forever preserved.
Now no one can access this history.
This is modern day Tokyo democracy.
You know what?
Edmund, open the server for one second.
Open the server for one second.
Close it, close it, close the server, close it Oh, wait Wait, give one person Access And then close the server
Now close the server I've chosen Alright I've chose El Mexica El Mexicon.
Close the server.
All right.
Put him in.
Put him inside.
That's right.
Yeah, all... Yeah, you want to talk now?
You want to talk?
You want to make a miniature prison.
make a miniature prison around him so he might kill make don't let him make a miniature prison around this guy so you can't move what the fuck is wrong with you yeah you just stay there that's like you're right
Also, set his spawn point inside the prison.
Make sure he can't, he can only, set his spawn point in that prison.
So he can never leave.
That to me will start.
Make sure he can't TP.
Revoke his TP rights too.
Revoke his TP rights.
He knows I didn't.
There you go.
Make sure he has no TP rights after.
He is in JV prison.
His life isn't over.
Should have thought of that before he said this.
What am I?
Say you're sorry right now.
Apologize.
Guess you'll live here.
I'll check back in a month if you still...
Guess you're not playing Minecraft for a month.
I'll come back next month to see if you'll say sorry.
Cat T.
Rebook his TP rights too.
Give him a...
No, he does not get anything.
He just gets a little prison.
Say sorry.
It'll all be over.
Working on removing human rights.
No, just try own rights.
Wait, how did he get in here?
What the fuck?
How did this get?
There are 29 players.
Who are the 29 players that are online?
I done it three on this SMV
Oh they're in the void Oh that's okay let them in the void a little longer It's alright it's okay they can live We don't care about that They can just be in the void a little longer But yeah this is more important
I don't know make them a little crazy a little longer You know they said they're like mentally stable now we're gonna change that bad ip bad bro you was never wait how did he get wait why did he get ip banned restricted what did he do how did he get ip banned where does your horse live Look at him.
He's trying to break free.
Look at him.
He's just banished forever.
Look at him go.
It's so cute.
He thinks he has rights.
Right on him.
Alright.
Take me to where he lives.
He said he has a horse.
Ninja.
restricted
yeah we'll fix that later we'll fix that in post
anyway take me to where he lives that's right you have a horse right that's right oh el mexican alright now where is his horse I heard he asked a horse did this horse run away he doesn't have a fucking horse oh a horse here where where is it take me to him I want to see the horse oh there is a horse take this horse back to the prison
take the horse take the horse to the prison I'll meet you there.
Who is it?
L.
Spawn Doki Lon.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I gotta help out too.
Alright.
Admin.
Put me inside as well.
CPM again.
I don't want to break it.
All right.
Apologize now.
Apologize.
For this horse.
It's gonna lay with the fishes.
Oh, you're not gonna apologize?
You're not?
Oh, you think you think you have rights here?
Indokilon?
You made a big mistake, Ella?
Just one simple apology.
Over my dead body?
Well, it seems like it'd be over your dead horse's body.
Oh look at that Look what I have here Wow Look at that Hmm What can I make with this leather I wonder Oh and I got some I got a saddle too Look at that
Oh you know you could have stopped all of this Oh You could have stopped all of it.
If you just said sorry.
Now your only friend is dead and it's all your fault.
Now what have we learned today?
Ironically evil.
What have we learned today?
You fool.
Oh, you know, look at this leather that I wonder.
What can I make with this leather?
I wonder.
Oh.
Let's see.
You know what?
Give me a picture.
Actually, no, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
I know what to do with this leather.
Just a little, you know.
A little memory.
So you can always see what happened to your little friend here.
Oh, and every corner you look.
Every corner you look.
You'll see a piece of him.
You could have stopped this, but you didn't.
Isn't that sad?
You had every- it was all stopped- you could have stopped it.
Every corner you look at, every angle, a piece of your horse is in your view.
And you could have stopped all of it.
Now you're gonna die alone.
You can never leave this area.
Just said sorry.
If you just said sorry, none of this would have happened.
Every angle, every place, your dead horse will be there.
You know what?
Admin, take me back to his house.
Take me back to his house, Admin.
You gotta put a reminder there too
Good turkey let the hate flow through you And do it No no it should go Where his bed lies So he'll always remember He'll sleep with that guilt for the rest of his life
You did this
you know what that was a good stream that was such a good stream right adamant i had a good time wait tb oh i'm gonna go back to my place what's it uh spawn doki you know guys i had a great stream today i have great time i'm so Happy we had a good time.
Did everyone have a good time watching today?
Nothing ever bad happens in Dokiland.
What do you mean?
That's a fun day.
Have a Dokiland.
Well, thank you for the vibe.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
Anyway, I'm going to call it here.
I think this...
Is that black?
Jack
Wait, I love that idea Hang all of them Wait, admin I love that idea Hang the turtle too
I love that idea I love that idea Hang the turtle as well
Good job, admin This was his idea Yeah, by the way, not mine.
You know, he's also part of the problem.
Lafayette, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For a horse called Blackjack, horse haunts of misfortune.
He sure is fortunate.
That's my haunts.
I love Blackjack.
But anyways, I hope you had a great time getting this little tour of Doki Land.
I had a great time seeing all your builds and collecting my hostages.
And everything.
Lunimo, thank you for the magenta soup pot.
Thank you, thank you.
Mod put Doki's spot point in the cell.
And my soul is yours.
You think that mods will listen to you?
I own the server.
If they want to keep their jobs, they better listen to me.
Look, see, he's happy.
Look at him.
He's so happy in his little prison cell.
but it's fun it's fun exploring my mind exploring the dokey smp again um you know making sure everyone knows who is who holds the most power in the server you know y'all remind these people once every month you know like just so they they remember just so they remember you know that I own the server Me,
thank you for the 10 gift and ships Thank you, thank you X factor, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you You sick Oh, he's okay Wait, heal him Make sure you heal him Okay, let's not hang him Yeah, heal the turtle We torture, we don't kill We gotta keep hostages alive Okay We torture.
We don't kill.
Uh, Medi, thank you.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This whole stream was Doki taking your anger out on us like a playground bully.
I'm so freaking scared.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't kill the horse.
L killed the horse.
He could have stopped it.
He could have stopped the blade from...
going down.
I didn't kill him.
It was his own fault.
Orca.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know.
You have to come back once a month to remind the dragons here.
That their life is mine.
We don't matter.
I am justice.
What do you mean?
The law.
I am the law.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, look.
There's the cat, too.
There we go.
It's like those people that like, you know, like put the heads on the spikes to warn people.
This is my warning to you all.
you that your life can be gone in just a snap it's
my warning to all
you're my hostages don't fuck with me
all right everyone i think it's a good way i think this is a a good way to call it i hope you guys had a fun time today i'll see you guys next month again when i visit doke lawn as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me it's oh it's raining now i think that's like a that like a sign from that's a good omen hey guys stay up for me to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye